Hi guys, thanks for coming today.
So, Chevy invited you to this focus group...
...to ask you what kind of person you think would drive...
...their all-new Lego batmobile.
Well, it's all black.
Probably someone with self-esteem issues?
Uh, what?
Yeah, screams "loner" to me.
Does it?
I'd go a different way with it.
I bet he's super outgoing and really popular.
Judging by these rocket launchers, this person's kind of defensive.
Defensive?
I am not defensive, you're defensive, I mean he's...
You're bad at reading people.
And look, there's no backseat.
Probably not many friends.
No, I bet the guy has a lot of friends...
...like, warehouses filled with friends.
Oh, okay.
What makes you say that, Batman?
Look at this.
It's awesome!
You look at the driver and you think, "I totally wanna be that guy."
Well, I think it's perfect for picking up the little ones from soccer practice.
Soccer? Oh, come on!
God, why didn't I create my own focus group, I don't need their opinion.